bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct notre grand témoin ce soir et
plutôt un homme rare dans les médias il
pilote l'un des groupes les plus
importants à l'Assemblée nationale
bonsoir Jean-Paul Mattei bonsoir et
merci d'être là vous êtes le président
des 51 députés modem à l'Assemblée le
parti de François Bayrou allié
indispensable à la majorité macroniste
qu'avez-vous fait depuis un an de cette
position stratégique on en parle
ensemble dans la deuxième partie mais on
commence ce soir par le partage de la
valeur c'est la nouvelle expression
consacrée pour désigner la participation
et l'intéressement des salariés au
bénéfice de leur entreprise l'accord
national conclut entre patronat et
syndicat va être transposé dans la loi
des députés en débattent en ce moment en
commission à l'Assemblée alors qu'est-ce
qui va changer très concrètement pour
les salariés les gains de pouvoir
d'achat feront-ils suffisants pour
compenser l'envoler des prix grands
débats dans un instant avec mes invités
sur ce plateau avant de retrouver 20h15
vous le savez les affranchis pour leurs
pattes parti pris et puis dans Bourbon
Express ce soir le plan caché de la
macronie pour déloger l'insomnie Éric
Coquerel de la tête de la commission des
finances bigrent on verra ça ensemble
vous êtes prêts Jean-Paul Matteis ça
vous regarde c'est parti
[Musique]
et si l'on partageait vraiment le gâteau
quelle part pour les salariés qui font
la richesse de leur entreprise
l'association capital travail grand
débat initié il y a bien longtemps par
le général de Gaulle après-guerre qui
resurgit aujourd'hui dans un contexte
d'inflation et après la crise des
retraites le partage de la valeur les
dividendes du travail de quoi parle-t-on
précisément combien peut-on espérer et
comment beaucoup de questions se soient
dans ce débat à la fois politique et
économique bonsoir Clémence guetter
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
député la France insoumise du
Val-de-Marne vous débattez ce soir avec
Gilbert 7 bonsoir bonsoir économiste et
professeur à Neoma Business School
bonsoir Agnès Brika bonsoir vous êtes
ambassadrice à la participation et à
l'intéressement qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire en amour il faut diffuser des
dispositifs de partage de valeur depuis
la loi du 16 août 2022 ou 4 5
dispositifs ont été présentés donc pas
faire de la pédagogie grâce à vous ce
soir enfin bonsoir Jean-François Mathieu
bienvenue vous êtes professeur à
l'Université Paris importante on
Sorbonne et spécialistes des syndicats
les syndicats presque tous les syndicats
ont signé cet accord ont le verra
Jean-Paul Mathey vous êtes entièrement
parti prenante dans ce débat puisque je
sais bien que ces sujets passionnent le
parti de François Bayrou le modèle c'est
une c'est une vieille Marotte et puis
vous avez aussi des propositions vous en
avez fait sur sur le la taxation des
dividendes c'est atelier pour l'instant
sans écho du président de la République
on commence par planter le décor après
la le salé de la réforme des retraites
le sucrées de la démocratie sociale il a
deux secondes le chrono de la cause
c'est parti
bonsoir mon cher Stéphane je vous invite
à vous retourner pour écouter Stéphane
blackovski dans son billet ça fait 6
mois qu'on accuse de gouvernement de
refuser tout dialogue avec les syndicats
et bien en ce moment il a l'occasion de
prouver le contraire en effet début
février alors qu'on était pourtant du
début de la bataille des retraites le
patronat et tous les syndicats sauf la
CGT ont signé un accord national pour un
meilleur partage des richesses dans
l'entreprise qu'on appelle le partage de
la valeur faut dire qu'aujourd'hui la
situation est assez injuste ne serait-ce
que parce que les salariés qui
travaillent dans des entreprises de plus
de 50 personnes eux ont touche une
participation c'est obligatoire et c'est
pas le cas par ailleurs donc on donne on
arrive à des chiffres ou dans des très
grandes entreprises
88% des salariés effectivement touche
d'une manière d'une autre une forme de
partage de la valeur dans les petites
entreprises on en reste seulement à 20%.
donc évidemment les partenaires sociaux
sont dit que ça serait mieux si les
entreprises entre 11 et 49 salariés donc
puissent elles aussi offrir un partage
de la valeur donc sous différentes
formes il y a la participation bénéfice
si l'entreprise fait des bénéfices ça
peut être de l'intéressement qu'on
employeur fixe un objectif et qu'on
l'atteint et puis la fameuse prime
Macron qui maintenant était rebaptisée
prime de partage de la valeur la PPV
donc de son côté le gouvernement lui il
s'efface il a juste promis de traduire
fidèlement cet accord entre les
partenaires sociaux dans un projet de
loi et donc en fin depuis 6 mois Olivier
du socle peut dire qu'il est sur la même
ligne que les syndicats
le dialogue social s'est ouvert il n'a
pas été interrompu pendant toute cette
période et il a permis d'aboutir un
accord c'est la raison pour laquelle je
présente ce texte devant vous avec un
principe simple l'accord et rien que
l'accord faut dire que le patron a comme
les syndicats ont prévenu si le projet
de loi devait modifier l'accord qu'ils
ont signé ensemble alors là non la CFDT
a dit ça serait un croche-pied la
démocratie sociale le Medef a même parlé
de coup de poignard dans le dos sauf
qu'aujourd'hui bah c'est mis en garde
des partenaires sociaux ça se retombe
plutôt contre l'opposition qui elle
aimerait bien modifier le projet de loi
de l'améliorer la nuit pèse par exemple
dit bah non si on veut vraiment partager
la valeur c'est pas des primes c'est des
augmentations de salaires qui sont il y
a bien sûr aussi la question des supers
profits il y a pas que la du peste qui
réfléchit la question c'est que
Jean-Paul Mattei il réfléchit aussi
parce que dans ce projet de loi même en
cas de projet exceptionnel et bien il y
a pas un partage automatique il y a
obligation d'ouvrir des négociations
enfin bon c'est pas parce qu'on ouvre
des négociations qu'on obtient
satisfaction bref du côté de la nupesse
en fait on enrage de voir que le le
gouvernement s'abrite derrière les
partenaires sociaux pour refuser tout
changement son projet de loi on écoute
Mathias Tavel vous êtes des hypocrites
parce que vous vous cachez derrière cet
accord national interprofessionnel comme
alibi de démocratie sociale alors que
vous venez d'écraser les syndicats les
manifestants et l'Assemblée nationale
pour imposer la retraite à 64 ans alors
côté gouvernement contraire c'est
l'inverse on se dit évidemment une gazon
de plus de essayer de tourner la page
des retraites puis pour Elisabeth Banks
c'est l'occasion d'afficher sa fibre
sociale je vous rappelle que dans le
temps elle était de gauche alors juste
un petit bémol sur les déclarations
Elisabeth borne sur quelle exagère quand
même un peu voir beaucoup le montant de
la fameuse prime de partage de la valeur
on l'écoute plus la prime de partage de
la valeur qu'on a voté à l'été dernier à
bénéficier à 5,5 millions de salariés en
2022 pour un montant moyen de près de
800 euros par mois
800 euros par mois alors oui je
comprends qu'elle fasse très fier de sa
de sa mesure si elle pour ça évidemment
mais c'est pas moi c'est 800 euros par
an évidemment donc on s'était déjà
mélangés au gouvernement dans les
chiffres sur les retraites faudrait pas
que ça recommence d'autant que ce sonore
il est affiché sur le site du
gouvernement vous voyez où on répète
tranquillement cette erreur cela dit le
débat ne fait commencer et peut-être que
parmi vous certains trouvent que cette
idée des 800 € par mois n'est pas si
mauvaise merci les taquin ce soir merci
merci beaucoup Stéphane Gilbert 7 on
clarifie le débat pour commencer
distinction
participation intéressante on n'y
connaît rien expliquez-nous monsieur le
professeur
je pense que vous soyez tout à fait
d'expliquer cela mais les deux les deux
dispositifs sont vraiment très
différents et d'ailleurs la
participation est un dispositif qui a
été voulu par le général de Gaulle
lui-même et ça avait donné lieu à
l'ordonnance de 1967 c'est l'idée que
pour décrisper pour déconctualiser les
relations de travail il faut donner un
intérêt commun aux détenteurs de
l'entreprise des actions d'entreprise et
aux travailleurs comment on les
associent bien sûr au fait que quand il
y a des profits les travailleurs
puissent gagner plus d'argent et bien
sûr les détenteurs de capital peuvent
aussi gagner plus d'argent par
l'augmentation de la valeur de leur
entreprise ou par la distribution de
dividendes
l'assiette de la participation c'est les
profits de l'entreprise
bénéfice l'entreprise vous voyez quelque
chose de très très particulier il y a
une formule un petit peu complexe pour
définir le montant de participation qui
est accordée aux travailleurs
l'intéressement peut être basé sur
n'importe quel objectif intermédiaire
décider par l'accord collectif
d'intéressement ça peut être le fait de
consommer moins de feuilles de papier et
de ramette de papier pour pour des
objectifs je dirais climatiques ça peut
être vous voyez une quantité de choses
décidée par les partenaires sociaux à
l'intérieur de l'entreprise très claire
même si une entreprise ne fait pas de
bénéfice
l'objectif d'intéressement atteint
impliquera bien sûr le paiement de la
prime d'intéressement ce qui est pas le
cas pour la participation bénéfice d'un
côté pour la participation objective de
l'autre objectif d'ailleurs de
déconflictualisation des relations
sociales est important dans un pays
comme la France la France et le pays le
plus conflictuel de tous les pays
avancés si on mesure cette
conflictualité par exemple par le nombre
de jours perdus en moyenne du fait de
grève ou de la récollectif de travail et
bien sur les trois dernières décennies
en moyenne la France et le pays qui est
en tête
on continue la pédagogie avec vous
on dit général de Gaulle on se souvient
du contexte il s'agissait aussi de
réduire les effets négatifs du
capitalisme il y avait aussi un parti
communiste qui était très fort à
l'époque on est bon sur le sujet ou au
contraire nos voisins européens je pense
au pays du Nord font bien mieux que nous
moi je trouve qu'on est plutôt bon en ce
qui concerne nos entreprises puisqu'on
est descendu au niveau de la
participation de 100 salariés de
l'époque de De Gaulle à 50 salariés ce
qui va pas c'est en dessous de 50
salariés et là il y a eu un vrai travail
qui a été mené depuis justement presque
novembre on va dire 2022 ou l'ensemble
des organisations patronales des
salariales ont reçu un courrier du
gouvernement leur demandant de se réunir
de négocier et on a obtenu un accord
février 2023 donc un rapport rapide
quand on regarde ils sont mis d'accord
patronat et salariés pour dire en
dessous de 49 salariés et bien on se
doit de mettre un des dispositifs
partagés dans
la loi d'août 2022 et la participation
devient obligatoire
la prime de partage de valeur dont on a
bien de parler même si les 800 euros on
sait bien que c'est pas par mois c'est
pour l'année mais il y a ensuite
l'intéressement il y a bien sûr la
participation mais on oublie
l'abonnement on le salarié donne un euro
pardon que le l'employeur peut en donner
jusqu'à 3 donc ça on l'oublie ça
fonctionne l'abonnement à l'abondement
pardonne-nous et puis enfin on a
l'actionnariat salarié on en parle
jamais assez quoi exactement alors c'est
justement rentrer dans le capital des
entreprises on voit un certain nombre
d'entreprises qui sont souvent cotés on
va eu des gros ETI mais ça peut être des
startups aujourd'hui et entreprises de
taille intermédiment dans le capital de
ces sociétés et au moment où on part à
la retraite et bien on vend ces actions
puisque en général ce sont des sociétés
qui sont cotées en bourse alors je vais
vous demander ça de me donner et
j'arrive aux politiques juste après
votre votre sentiment sur l'ambition de
cet accord il y a de la démocratie
sociale ça on peut s'en féliciter ça
compte dans une démocratie même si la
CGT n'a pas signé suffisamment ambitieux
selon vous Agnès Picard cet accord alors
ambitieux dans la mesure il y a une
égalité qui doit se faire au niveau des
salariés puisqu'il faut jamais oublier
qu'on a plus de quand même 80%
d'entreprises qui ont moins de 50
salariés donc il faut avoir un respect
de l'égalité en disant on redescend les
seuils jusqu'à 11 après on parlera juste
ça donc pour moi dans l'égalité le
principe même c'est juste cette
ambitieux c'est autre chose on n'a pas
donné de Quantum c'est quoi un quantum
c'est-à-dire quel est le montant
certains n'ont même parlé de 10 euros ça
suffirait ah non il y a donc un principe
il n'y a pas de Quantum et on peut
imaginer qu'à ce moment-là ça soit pas
aussi ambitieux qu'on le voulait le
quantum c'est quoi c'est le seuil
minimal c'est le montant le montant
vacciné qu'un des dispositifs de partage
valeur ça soit 10 euros et là ce serait
le summum de la caricature Clémence
guetter on y est la démocratie sociale
celle que vous réclamiez dans
l'hémicycle ils ont tous signé c'est à
peu près 70% des syndicats présentatifs
pas la CGT l'accord chaque accord c'est
ce qu'il demande des deux côtés vous
allez le dénaturer dans l'hémicycle bon
on va amender on est là pour amender je
doute que ça require recueille beaucoup
de suffrages je pense que nous allons
être minoritaire sur ce sujet parce que
on a déjà eu l'occasion de parler des
questions de prix mais de salaire dans
le projet de loi pouvoir d'achat de
l'été dernier et déjà les macronistes
étaient alliés au rassemblement national
et à la droite pour voter contre
l'augmentation du SMIC etc donc on voit
à peu près ce que les rapports de force
peuvent donner sur ce type de sujet je
veux juste revenir sur le cadre de
l'accord déjà les syndicats posent tous
la question que nous nous posons
c'est-à-dire des primes d'accord mais
c'est insuffisant et je vais y revenir
ce qui est important ce serait
l'augmentation des salaires dans ce pays
parce que ça ne crée pas les mêmes
droits notamment c'est les entreprises
pour la retraite mais le cadre de
l'accord était contraint par le
gouvernement c'est la première des
choses donc ensuite en effet certains
syndicats l'ont signé parce que ça
augmente le
[Musique]
que vous répondez à Clémence guetter où
sont les salaires ou est la justice
sociale cet accord est-il suffisant à
vous alors d'abord cet accord est très
riche parce que il le traite beaucoup de
sujets il traite aussi de carrière de
profils de carrière de la notion de
valeur qu'est-ce que la valeur et puis
il y a tout un volet effectivement
partage de la valeur et autres et c'est
un accord qui est compliqué à
retranscrire dans les textes d'ailleurs
le texte qu'on nous propose
n'englobe pas l'ensemble de l'accord il
y a certains points qui seront qui vont
relever du poids réglementaire mais pour
revenir sur le débat sur
fameux super
c'est dit plusieurs fois dans l'accord
que ces primes ou ce cette participation
je partage de la valeur ne doit pas se
substituer au salaire quelles sont
aujourd'hui elles se substitue c'est ce
que promet en tout cas le ministre du
Travail on a eu un débat sur notamment
ce qu'on appelait la prime Macron le
prime partage de la valeur ça évolué
on est passé à seuil de 1000 euros on
est monté à 3000 euros jusqu'à 6000
euros c'est simplement une mesure de
pouvoir d'achat ponctuel qui
correspondait à mieux être de
l'entreprise à un moment moi ce que je
trouve intéressant cet accord c'est
qu'il ouvre également l'ensemble des
entreprises agnès Bricard le disait les
grandes entreprises à limite il y a des
grandes entreprises et puis il y a les
petites et on a l'impression que les
salariés sont entre guillemets un peu
moins bien traités dans les petits
entreprises que dans les grandes
entreprises et là cet accord ouvre le
spectre de l'ensemble et la réflexion
sur véritablement la participation
l'obligation c'est quand même le
bénéfice net fiscal au moins égal à 1%
du chiffre d'affaires pendant trois ans
la difficulté pour une petite entreprise
on connaît mieux moi je connais mieux de
parler mon expérience
professionnelle je connais mieux ce type
d'entreprise tous ces citrons d'une
étude notariale
tout c'est très compliqué la
participation la mise en jeu de la
participation la réserve de
participation et souvent ce seuil de
salariés troublez moi je trouve c'est
une avancée importante parce que ça
ouvre la réflexion sur une évolution de
l'entreprise des petites comme les
grandes et on a fixé le seuil de nos
salariés ça s'applique que pour les
sociétés donc je vais pas rentrer dans
un débat parce qu'un débat fiscal aussi
mais c'est on partage entre les salariés
le super dividende c'était pas du tout
du tout la même chose c'était en quelque
sorte un bénéfice et quand il est dans
l'entreprise il est utile il est investi
il permet de je dirais à la fois de se
développer de faire la transition
énergétique
de faire grossir l'entreprise et si les
distribués il va aller chez les
actionnaires et il perd un peu sa nature
il rémunère les actionnaires ce qui est
tout à fait normal mais quand on
distribue et c'était l'essence de
l'amendement sur la dividendes qui a
fait couler beaucoup
peut-être mais il a permis de poser de
se poser la question de un bénéfice qui
est investi en entreprise
utile il est nécessaire et hyper
dividende c'est différent un dividende
qui distribué il est utile pour les
actionnaires mais si il déborde si on
peut dire on peut se poser la question
sur sa fiscalité Jean-François Mathieu
ce qui nous regarde ce disent je suis
salarié alors évidemment il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de toutes petites entreprises
c'est la grande majorité en France mais
quand même les PME c'est pas rien dans
notre pays ils se disent combien combien
je fais avoir qu'est-ce que ça va
changer très concrètement pour moi
évidemment il y a une certaine déception
parce que
l'intention d'étendre au plus petites
entreprises tous ces dispositifs est
évidemment très bonnes d'ailleurs c'est
le sens de l'histoire si vous voulez en
France comme ça a été rappelé mais déjà
vous remarquerez que je crois qu'on a
reporté à janvier 2025 simplement la
première année ou quelque chose pourrait
apparaître à votre avis
ce serait une bonne idée
non mais le problème principal c'est que
par exemple voyez dans les petites
entreprises qui est prévue c'est au fond
le choix il y a plein de dispositifs et
finalement le patron choisira celui que
qu'il souhaite a priori retenir il y a
beaucoup dans l'obligation de
participation quand même quand on
remplit les conditions elle devient
obligatoire dans l'accord non vous avez
le choix des dispositifs vous avez le
choix
2025 puisque vous donnez mais c'est un
accord le 1er janvier 2025 c'est un
accord qui était négocié patrona salarié
mais qui dit c'est au moment où ça
s'applique ça peut être la prime de
partage de valeur qui peut être de 500
qui peut être 2000 il peut aller à 3000
et ça peut être un intéressement et du
coup bah il a des outils il a des outils
mais il est obligé d'en choisir un alors
on fait de la simplification
pardonnez-moi de nous interrompre mais
on fait de la simplification parce que
pour faire d'égalité il faut de la
simplification on est bien d'accord donc
dès lors qu'on fait de la simplification
on a vu par exemple sur la prime partage
de valeur qu'on a simplifié au maximum
pour que justement il y ait même plus
justement pour les salariés les neufs 70
qu'on le retenez on leur donne à net et
il y a plus justement ni c'est ingénieur
DS comme on l'appelle plus de forfait
social non plus dans le cas des
entreprises qui en avait jusqu'à 20%
au-delà de 250 et ça tient jusqu'au 31
décembre 2023 donc c'est vrai que passer
au 1er janvier 2025 qui a été fait pour
l'intéressement c'est que l'employeur
peut décider lui-même ça s'appelle une
décision unilatérale d'employeur DIU il
peut décider lui-même de mettre en place
sans accord de branche sans les deux
tiers des salariés sans son CSE il peut
te mettre en place un accord
d'intéressement et on a fait en sorte de
le dématérialiser et qui trouve en trois
pages en un clic alors
je vous donne la parole pour répondre à
votre question sur les salariés il y a
évidemment une certitude complète sur la
portée du dispositif combien ça
représentera si pour le salarié
bénéficiaire moyen en France les
différents dispositifs c'est à peu près
2400 euros ou 2005
si vous voulez qu'est-ce qui se passera
dans les petites entreprises on en sait
absolument rien je vais prendre un
exemple
traditionnellement la participation
obligatoire sur les bénéfices il y a une
formule de calcul dit de droit commun or
là on remarque que et renvoyé à la
négociation soit d'entreprise soit de
branches le fait qu'on peut faire mieux
ou moins bien
ou moins bien d'ailleurs qu'en fait mais
oui c'est à dire que la part qui revient
au salarié dans le ce qu'il finalement
la part qui leur revient on pourrait
rappeler la formule de calcul mais cette
part elle peut être plus faible pour la
loi de l'association pour les grandes
entreprises comment ce qui était déjà
vrai dans la loi actuelle sur l'écran et
on peut faire mieux on peut faire mieux
dans la loi actuelle
c'est pas du gagnant-gagnant mais
forcément non mais dans les petites
entreprises on va pas appliquer
nécessairement la participation qu'on
soit clair on va appliquer soit la PPV
la prime de partage la prime Macron pour
aller l'intéressement avec cette
décision unilatérale de l'employeur
parce que n'oublions pas dans les
petites entreprises ce qui compte c'est
l'homme ou la femme qui dirige une
équipe parfois de 15 20 25 personnes
tout le monde se connaît donc ce qui est
essentiel c'est que le l'employeur va
décider unilatéralement il va avoir des
contrats d'intéressement qui font à
peine trois pages c'est l'URSSAF qui a
mis en place de façon très facile en
appuyant sur un clic on a trois pages
qui se présentent on a un contrat
d'intéressement là où avant il y avait
25 pages d'accord donc attention n'est
pas encore simplifiée allez-y rapidement
rapidement je peux dire quand même que
depuis le ce débat sur le la prime
Macron ça quand même il y a plus de
prime qui avait auparavant dans les
petits entreprises on a également aussi
une démarche intellectuelle qui fait
qu'on a un véritable dialogue qui se
fait avec ses salariés franchement moi
je constate dans les petits et moyennes
entreprises une nécessité d'ouvrir ce
dialogue et je trouve que c'est
intéressant qu'on est cet accord donc il
faut le voir comme une mesure
pédagogique la société de des
entreprises des petites entreprises il y
a 30 ans sont plus les mêmes aujourd'hui
et moi je trouve que c'est une avancée
et puis on vous montre un reportage
d'abord c'est un accord collectif un
accord national interprofessionnel moi
j'ai pas à me substituer au syndicat
pour savoir ce qui est ce qui est bon
pour les salariés je vois que le le
représentant le chef du premier syndicat
de France dit qu'il tient absolument à
ce que cet accord soit transcrit
pas mais voyez donc
moi je ne sais pas mieux que lui ce qui
est important ce qui défend bien
l'intérêt des salariés je pense que
c'est c'est lui qui est la personnidoine
pour savoir comment représenter porter
l'intérêt des salariés c'est une
première chose deuxième chose la France
est un pays particulier quand on regarde
l'évolution du partage céréprofit sur
les trois décennies à partir de 1988 une
fois qu'on a absorbé les chocs
pétroliers on voit que ça se déforme en
faveur des profits on est l'un des rares
pays au monde dans lequel ça se déforme
en faveur des profits alors expliquer ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que il y a
moins pour les salaires plus pour les
profits
excusez-moi ça se déforme en faveur des
salaires des salariés j'avais mal
compris de la masse salariale la part
des profits diminue dans la valeur
ajoutée et nous sommes l'un des rares
pays dans ce cas là parmi tous
dans cette situation donc on l'a publié
dans les meilleures revues du monde ça a
été enfin pour pour ce genre de choses
statistique dans un débat sur la
semi-cardisation de la société vous
étiez venu sur un débat salaire qui
faisait que on est coincé au niveau des
inégalités salariales qu'est-ce qui se
passe en ce moment les basses salaires
sont protégés le SMIC les protège
complètement on est l'un des rares pays
dans ce cas là je préside le groupe
d'experts sur le SMIC et dans notre
rapport annuel nous avons publié des
évaluations auxquelles tout le monde
peut se reporter et auquel je vous
invite à vous reporter
71 en dessous du SMIC quand des
minimases branches sont au-dessus du
SMIC les gens sont payés au SMIC
évidemment il y a 12 millions de
travailleurs
au SMIC ne veulent aussi que les gens
sont rémunération ça écrase la
hiérarchie des salaires au voisinage du
SMIC regardez notre rapport
justement vous apprendrez des choses
mais la dispersion des salaires juste
la dispersion des salaires a diminuer
parce que les salaires moyens n'ont pas
augmenté autant que l'inflation les
selles est élevés n'ont pas augmenté
autant que l'inflation les bases
salaires ont augmenté autant que
l'inflation à cause de fixation c'est un
cas unique parmi tous les pays avancés
bon les gens au SMIC dans ce pays vivent
mal voire très mal notamment du fait de
l'inflation ils arrivent plus à se
nourrir ils se prive de repas donc c'est
ça la situation sociale du pays je
voulais juste revenir sur la question de
la prime Macron là où c'est de l'arnaque
c'est que vous avez montré de
l'enthousiasme dans votre introduction
se dire on va partager les richesses etc
c'est qu'en fait c'est un dispositif qui
n'est jamais obligatoire donc les
entreprises vont toujours chercher le
moins 10 ans elles peuvent revenir
dessus puisque c'est ponctuel alors que
des salaires c'est plus gravés dans le
marbre et donc ce sont des vrais droits
pour les salariés
au salaire pour 30% des primes ça a été
montré ça se substitue à des
augmentations de salaire ça en fait
environ 1,5 et un arbitrage qui est fait
dans les entreprises manquer en
employeurs préfèrent une prime plutôt
que faire une augmentation pérenne pour
40 % des prêts Macron s'étendent sous de
500 euros le montant moyen c'est 800
euros donc si vous voulez dans des
années où il y a une telle inflation
c'est absolument elle commence un tout
petit peu qui n'est pas des moindres
c'est que il y a pas de cotisation
sociale sur cette question et que par
exemple après Macron c'est moins 1
milliard tout ce genre de dispositifs
dont on parle c'est moins 9 milliards
pour la sécurité sociale et après on va
nous faire une seconde réforme des
retraites en nous disant on va peut-être
aller jusqu'à 65 parce que on n'est pas
encore là même si le corps
on va justement voir vous le disiez ça
existe déjà dans les petites entreprises
ça s'appelle l'intéressement en fonction
d'objectif c'est un reportage avec les
équipes de France Télévisions d'Alex
Giraud Carlier et Christophe Tixier
regardez c'est concret on en parle juste
après
on septembre dernier les salariés de
cette PME en aménagement paysager ont
touché une prime exceptionnelle de 3000
euros
les prix j'essaie de les mettre un petit
peu de côté soit pour
peut-être la retraite ou quelque chose
comme ça parce qu'on sait pas trop
comment ça va se passer ça peut aider
beaucoup donc c'est comme si ça faisait
aussi un très bon mois le patron veut
même la doubler sous forme de prime
d'intéressement son entreprise fait des
bénéfices et pour lui il est normal de
partager les bons résultats avec ses
salariés la prime sur le partage de la
valeur est une prime qui est
désocialisée et qui n'est pas imposé
pour les salariés donc le salarié qui
reçoit six mois je verse mon entreprise
vers 3000 euros ça veut dire que le
salarié reçoit 3000 euros sans impôts à
payer donc il y a quand même un effet
domaine ici aussi seulement 35 salariés
mais cette agence en communication
touristique a mis en place un accord
d'intéressement la prime peut
représenter jusqu'à deux mois de salaire
de quoi motiver les équipes quand on
parle de collectif vraiment d'une équipe
ça se joue dans l'intéressement et
ensuite oui tout au long de l'année on
le voit parfois des des remarques de
personnes qui disent bah tiens tel bon
résultat tel voilà tel bon résultat tel
contrat bah ça va nous faire aussi un
bon intéressement Alice cabanov la
toucher plusieurs fois au total près de
9000 euros j'ai pu utiliser les sommes
accumulées pour pouvoir aider à financer
l'achat de mon premier appartement ce
partage des bénéfices que ces deux
sociétés ont devancé pourrait bientôt
devenir obligatoire pour les entreprises
à partir de 11 salariés
voilà c'est pas rien quand même
concrètement dans dans une vie
quotidienne de pouvoir toucher les frais
de bénéficiaires bien sûr mais vous
aviez raison de souligner que la
situation est malheureusement très
inégale entre les très grandes
entreprises qui versent beaucoup et puis
le fait qu'ils passent ce type de
dispositif dans les plus petites ça
c'est certain ce qui était très bien
indiqué dans le reportage et on le sait
très bien c'est que les dispositifs de
parts d'intéressement sont bons pas
seulement pour les salariés parce qu'ils
encaissent tout de suite leur prime
d'intéressement et mais aussi c'est bon
pour la performance des entreprises il y
a un effet positif sur la productivité
qui a été démontré dans les études
internationales je voudrais revenir sur
la question de la négociation j'étais
frappé en lisant l'exposé des motifs de
la loi
de voir que le gouvernement insiste sur
le fait que ils ont utilisé l'article 1
du Code du travail en proposant aux
partenaires dès le mois de septembre je
crois de négocier sur ce sujet et ils
tiennent à le rappeler l'article 1 du
Code du travail ce qu'on appelle la loi
Larcher
simplement pose le fait c'est l'article
1 que avant
tout projet de loi
présenté par le gouvernement portant sur
les questions sociales d'emplois de
travail etc et bien il faut proposer aux
partenaires sociaux de négocier et s'il
le souhaite ils vont le faire et donc au
fond c'est transposé en France qui
existe au niveau européen depuis
longtemps sauf que c'est là que c'est
assez pardon pas cocasse mais on peut
quand même s'amuser ou remarquer que
bien souvent naturellement le
gouvernement se dispense de le faire par
exemple sur les retraites
le fameux index senior c'est une ce sont
des dispositions du Code du travail
vous voyez donc on modifie on fait
quelque chose qui relève des partenaires
sociaux on ne propose jamais à ce
moment-là aux partenaires on leur a pas
dit ah bah tiens en raison de l'article
1 vous allez discuter tel ou tel aspect
en fait de façon générale on ne le fait
pas parce qu'en France à la différence
d'autres pays on n'a pas assez de
culture de le respect des réseaux
sociaux donc les partenaires font un bon
accord les partenaires font un bon
accord bon ils sont contents ils font un
accord majoritaire c'est très bien mais
ce qu'on peut regretter c'est que ce
soit pas plus souvent que effectivement
le politique je vais confirmer il y a
une dimension politique importante et un
contexte dans lequel arrive après la
crise des retraites cet accord
interprofessionnel il va être voté c'est
presque sûr il y aura peut-être quelques
changements mais tels que les rapports
de force se présente je crois que les
choses sont dites non il faut pas on a
cet accord moi je trouve que la méthode
est bonne la méthode est bonne donc il
faut il faut s'en féliciter
je trouve que il va permettre de faire
de la pédagogie aussi dans les
entreprises et de remettre un peu un
équilibre entre les petites et les
grandes entreprises parce que souvent on
n'est pas dans le même monde en tant que
salarié et ça me semble important il y a
aussi un volet actionnariat pouvoir être
actionnaire avec les distributions
gratuites aussi et je crois que
l'entreprise il y aura aussi des
associés vous voyez cette entrepreneur
que vous voyez peut-être qu'il a déjà
identifié dans ces salariés des gens qui
qui reprendront sur l'entreprise donc je
crois qu'il faut qu'on vraiment on
s'ouvre et je trouve que la méthode qui
a été prise par les partenaires sociaux
et la bonne méthode qu'il faut il faut
compléter il faut discuter il faut
vraiment il faut saisir cette chance
j'entends ce que vous dites sur les
salaires l'écrasement le SMIC
l'écrasement des de la de la grille des
salaires bien sûr que c'est que c'est un
sujet bien sûr qu'on va pas substituer
ces primes au salaire on est tout à fait
d'accord mais une prime quand
l'entreprise va bien elle verse elle
verse une prime le à partir du moment
un chiffre d'affaires qui en progression
on n'est pas sur des primes on est sur
une augmentation des salaires une
discussion des grilles de salaire si
vous avez
le fait d'avoir décroché un bon contrat
qui vous permet de d'avoir un chiffre
d'affaires un peu supérieur et donc
dégager c'est peut-être exceptionnel
c'est pas dans la continuité mais je
crois que par à coup on va bâtir des
vrais projets d'entreprise même pour les
petites entreprises je vous vois aussi
de la tête c'est un pas en avant je peux
clairement dire sur ce que
rebondir l'augmentation de chiffre
d'affaires dans des entreprises de 11 à
49 salariés à du sens et c'est un
critère qui a été retenu dans les
simplifications qui sont proposées pour
l'intéressement donc je voudrais le dire
parce que c'est vraiment un point
essentiel et nous expert-comptable on
est en train de le dire à nos PME c'est
à dire là où on est vraiment présent à
95% du PME en leur dit attention
n'oubliez pas prime de partage de valeur
et intéressement simplifie c'est dit
merci on va s'arrêter là on va regarder
vous il y a un dire un tout petit mot
monsieur le professeur je sais que vous
avec l'article L1 du Code du travail
l'article est l'un du Code du travail
transforme le Parlement transforme
pardon les partenaires sociaux auprès
législateur mais on peut pas enlever
bien sûr au Parlement la possibilité
d'amander un texte il y a une véritable
difficulté là à laquelle il faut
concurrence de la légitimité qu'on soit
de gauche de droite n'importe où
démocratie sociale versus démocratie
parlementaire on s'arrête là peut-être
vous reviendrez pour cette autre débat
on aurait pu dire beaucoup de choses
aussi le rachat d'action promis par le
Président de la République on n'entend
plus parler de ça peut-être ça va
s'inviter dans ce débat dans l'hémicycle
merci merci d'être venu débattre sur LCP
vous restez avec moi Jean-Paul Mathey
dans une petite dizaine de minutes les
parties pris de nos affranchis ce soir
regarde sur la guerre de Richard Verdi
qui revient tout juste du don-basse le
front ukrainien en pleine
contre-offensive retour avec Jean-Rémy
Baudot sur la vidéo
sordide de la violente à Bordeaux bras
de fer local et faits divers national et
puis dans Bourbon Express ce soir de
quoi nous parlez-vous Stéphanie despier
et bien on parlera de la majorité qui
veut remplacer Éric Coquerel à la tête
de la commission des finances on verra
ça à tout à l'heure d'abord avec vous
Jean-Paul Mathey on va revenir sur votre
année de président du groupe moderne à
l'Assemblée vous êtes d'un naturel
discret pas franchement d'ailleurs à
vous entendre en direct vous êtes dans
l'ombre mais c'est dans l'ombre que
parfois on est le meilleur des
politiques très proches de François
Bayrou aussi dont vous avez l'amour des
Pyrénées en partage et puis comme lui
vous êtes capable de quelques coups de
griffes à l'Allier macronique macroniste
quand vous le jugez
utile mais à quoi ça sert pas forcément
à grand chose pour le moment vous nous
le direz la vitesse est signée ce soir
pierre Michael Carniel on en parle
ensemble juste après
si on vous invite Jean-Paul Mattei c'est
parce que vous êtes à la tête d'une
formation stratégique et surtout
indispensable pour consolider une
majorité présidentielle à l’assemblée le
groupe modem un groupe charnière situé
entre Renaissance et horizon en 5 ans
vous êtes le seul groupe du bloc à avoir
gagné des députés passant de 47 à 51
élus Jean-Paul Mattei vous rentrez à
l'Assemblée nationale en 2017 en tant
que député des Pyrénées-Atlantiques
avant de prendre la tête du groupe 5 ans
plus tard vous êtes également le bras
droit de François Bayrou comme lui vous
êtes un centre triste historique
la pierre angulaire de votre parcours
politique c'est la défense de la justice
sociale vous l'avez montré en défendant
une proposition de loi sur la taxation
des super dividendes soutenu par les
insoumis les ennemis jurés de
renaissance
on est vraiment sur une notion de super
dividende plus 20% par rapport à la
moyenne des dividendes ça incite les
entreprises à investir leur bénéfice
dans le développement dans la transition
donc je pense que c'est quelque chose de
vertueux voilà est-ce qu'on peut se
poser ce problème
Jean-Paul Mattei vous êtes un homme
politique à l'ancienne loin des coups
d'éclat et du buzz médiatique vous
préférez plutôt les compromis en
coulisses fort de votre expérience en
tant que notaire qui a fait de vous un
expert du foncier vous vous rêvez
maintenant en tant que ministre du
logement lors d'un prochain remaniement
encore faut-il que le futur gouvernement
ne penche pas trop à droite une
hypothèse qui n'est pas au goût de
François Bayrou pour ma part en tout cas
je trouverai que un virage comme il est
appelé par les uns ou par les autres
serait le contraire de ce que nous avons
proposé aux Français aujourd'hui
alors nous avons une question pour vous
Jean-Paul Mattei quand la majorité pour
adopter un texte se joue à une
quarantaine de voix la coalition avec la
droite n'est-elle pas la seule solution
pour sortir de l'immobilisme
alors réponse à cette question la
coalition avec la droite aujourd'hui
pour sortir des blocages au Parlement
c'est pas la solution la solution
écouter quand on s'est engagé en 2017
derrière Emmanuel Macron
il y avait une offre politique on
connaît depuis pas mal d'années
notamment et François Bayrou et même
antérieurement avec Valéry Giscard
d'Estaing sur une cécité du gouverner la
France au centre donc le centre c'est le
centre donc c'est à la fois un peu
droite et un peu de gauche aussi voilà
donc
politique il manque une quarantaine de
voix 38 exactement
et quand on fait la nouvelle lecture de
notre hémicycle
je regrette moi il y a la nupes qui est
à je dirais une organisation politique
et qui a fonctionné qui a une certaine
réussite mais on sent les membres de la
nuit passe un peu bloquer pour essayer
de s'ouvrir de discuter moi je crois
qu'il faut que
son capacité de s'affranchir un peu et
trouver des ponts un peu à droite un peu
à gauche trouver des ponts en un an on a
regardé le bilan de cette première année
64% des projets de loi ont été adoptés
grâce aux voix des républicains la
droite n'est-elle pas déjà le partenaire
naturel d'Emmanuel Macron on a des je
dirais des membres du LR qui sont tout à
fait responsables et qui ont été aux
affaires et qui se connaissent qu'on a
des membres du gouvernement qui ont été
de la même famille un premier ministre
LR à Matignon Gérard Larcher tiens c'est
pas le plus radical à droite c'est non
pour vous sinon je le sens pas je vous
dis franchement c'est pas l'esprit dans
lequel on était en 2017 et on a envie de
continuer cette majorité ça veut dire
quoi c'est un casus belli pour vous non
votre riez pas des textes s'ils étaient
négociés avec leurs compétence du
Président de la République c'est pas de
la mienne nous on est dans la majorité
c'est pas une question de personnes moi
je dois vous dire on travaille très bien
avec Elizabeth borne moi je travaille
très très bien qu'ils avaient de bord
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure elle a se
positionnement un peu à gauche dans les
côtes cette capacité de oui d'écoute et
de reste après le 14 juillet je pense
que encore une fois c'est pas moi de le
dire mais je pense qu'on a besoin de
stabilité et qu'on a besoin de rebondir
avec l'équipe alors peut-être
remanier j'en sais rien c'est vraiment
pas le sujet c'est vraiment il faut
qu'on travaille qu'on se concentre et
qu'on arrive vous êtes borniste vous
savez que ça existe ce mot maintenant ça
vous fait sourire allez parlons du bilan
de la majorité un an après les textes
passent mais à quel prix celui de
s'éloigner un peu plus à chaque fois de
notre capacité à réformer est-ce que
vous savez qui a dit ça
et ben je vais vous le dire c'est Naïma
Moutchou la vice-présidente du groupe
horizon le groupe d'Edouard Philippe à
l'Assemblée nationale dans un papier du
monde aujourd'hui est-ce qu'elle a pas
un petit peu raison
alors on a vécu on a vécu une période
notamment avec la réforme des retraites
on n'a pas pu et même les textes
financiers qu'on a qu'on a adopté dans
le cas de du 49-3 là je savais que notre
groupe on était assez favorable d'aller
au vote sur les retraites ensuite moi je
considère ce qu'on veut bien dire il y a
eu un vote c'est-à-dire il y a pas eu de
censure du gouvernement donc à la fin
des 577
si vraiment si vraiment on avait on le
voit bien d'ailleurs regardez le rapport
du corps aujourd'hui on considère qu'il
y a quand même des avancées
dans ce texte donc voilà je crois qu'il
faut pas qu'on se pose un peu sur ce
texte on a nous revendiquer une clause
de revoyure dans le texte des retraites
pour 2027 je pense que le temps viendra
d'ailleurs les gens constatent
aujourd'hui quand ils font leur calcul
que les 64 ans c'est pas aujourd'hui ça
sera en octobre 2027 ça sera 3 ans et 3
mois on pourra remettre la réforme sur
le métier si nécessaire à mon avis c'est
une réforme qui est pas stabilisée du
fait qu'il y a plein de paramètres et
qu'il faut chaque fois réfléchir sur son
efficacité alors au modem on connaît
votre attachement à la justice sociale
et au juste la juste répartition des
efforts demandés à chacun c'est un peu
l'ADN du centrisme à la François Bayrou
mais à la Jean-Paul Mattei également
votre taxe sur des super dividendes on
en a parlé qui avait fait sensation et
tomber dans les oubliettes de Bercy
qu'avez-vous concrètement obtenu sur le
fond Jean-Paul Mattei je pense que j'ai
obtenu qu'on en débattre qu'on en
discute qu'on se pose des interrogations
sur la contribution des revenus du
travail par rapport au revenu du capital
je crois que on a on a fait des réformes
en 2017 qui étaient utiles et nécessaire
maintenant est-ce qu'on peut se poser et
dire est-ce que on peut pas essayer de
rééquilibrer
ça veut dire quoi agnèsf vert par
exemple c'est l'économiste qui a
travaillé
contact les choses immobiles on n'a pas
forcément la trésorerie pour faire face
moi je considère qu'il y a d'autres
outils comme sur les flux sur les
plus-values et autres sur l'immobilier
c'est un sujet pour relancer je pense le
logement il faut qu'on s'interroge et
qu'on se pose des bonnes questions on a
un système qui favorise la rétention
foncière qui favorise pas la circulation
bien évidemment sur les résidences
principales il faut pas y toucher parce
que on peut on est dans un système
d'exonération on essaie dans le parcours
résidentiel normal de toute personne qui
construit sa vie on est dans une très
très grave crise du logement j'en
profite des voitures
qui augmentent il y a très peu de
construction par rapport aux besoins il
y a eu le Conseil national de la
refondation avec tous les acteurs très
en colère après les annonces qui ont été
jugées dans la presse qu'il fallait un
choc fiscal sur le logement je le pense
bon on en est pas là quand j'ai écouté
la première ministre et Bruno Luère on
en est pas encore là mais vous dites
référence à cet article que le logement
est maltraité aujourd'hui mais parce que
il y a deux choses l'immobilier c'est un
quand c'est loué à long terme au titre
d'une résidence principale pour des gens
qui veulent se loger
par rapport location meublée saisonnière
Airbnb là on a moi je considère à ce
moment-là le logement devient vertueux
c'est-à-dire que l'investisseur qui veut
mettre sur le marché des biens pour les
louer pour pour des familles avec un
loyer encadré avec une recherche aussi
de qualité environnementale
devrait être mieux traité c'est aussi
important qu'on investissement
immobilier si je comprends bien vous au
modem vous n'êtes pas complètement
allergique à l'impôt pas complètement
allergique à l'impôt sur des plus riches
et comment vous expliquer que ce
gouvernement soit manifestement
allergique on a l'impression que vous
considérez aucun pays peut s'apaiser et
rester attractif
mais alors que considère que ça fait
fuir les investisseurs
et si on a trop de taxation on a peur de
faire fuir les personnes je pense qu'il
faut qu'on ait une discussion c'est très
technique à la fiscalité et je pense que
la fiscalité et la technicité fiscale
pour rejoindre le politique en trouvant
des solutions par exemple sur les
plus-values immobilières on peut très
bien se poser la question de dire en
prenant pas les gens entre elles on se
laissant un peu de temps de dire qu'à un
moment il y aura peut-être une taxation
qui sera pallier qui permettra de
fluidifier le marché et d'entraîner des
ventes plus facilement que ce système de
blocage je crois qu'il faut qu'on met
sur les super profils et super
dividendes aussi il faut y revenir et
parler beaucoup du logement alors sur
les super sur les super dividendes j'ai
dit d'ailleurs que la flat tax 12,8
fiscalité 17,2 de contribution sociale
12,1 sur le en quelque sorte pas étrange
très élevé on rappelle que la première
tranche est à 11 même avant on était en
dessous la première si les 51 députés
que vous pilotez qui sont absolument
indispensables au macronie seront
entendus cette fois parce qu'on a
l'impression que c'est pas toujours le
cas il faut que je vous pose la question
sur Richard Ferrand parce que le temps
nous est compté est-ce que vous l'avez
compris l'ancien président de
l'Assemblée nationale dans le Figaro à
la question regrettez-vous qu'Emmanuel
Macron ne puisse pas se représenter en
2027 il répond qu'il regrette tout ce
qui brille de la libre expression de la
souveraineté populaire dans la
Constitution comme la limitation dans le
temps du mandat présidentiel changeons
tout cela dit-il avant de rétropédaler
sur Sud Radio
bon je pense qu'il y a des réactions se
sont ainsi quinquennat législatives
juste après une élection limitation à
deux mandats ainsi c'est ainsi
Emmanuel Macron le président Emmanuel
Macron disparaîtra pas la scène
politique
d'avoir dit ça c'est je sais pas je sais
pas du tout mais on peut s'interroger
sur la limitation des mandats quand on a
des gens de qualité et si le suffrage
universel leur donne encore leur chance
c'est vrai mais bon c'est comme ça je
crois qu'il faut surtout pas revenir sur
cette règle de demanda
consécutifs je dis bon du monde à
consécutif voilà donc il faudra
souhaiter d'ailleurs Nicolas Sarkozy
d'un tout petit mot François Bayrou
candidat en 2027 vous le souhaitez
alors vous savez François Bayrou était
conduit à trois fois au présidentielles
il a il a la capacité je dirais
à assumer ce combat parce que c'était
c'est un véritable combat on verra je
dirais le temps n'est pas n'est pas
n'est pas c'est pas le sujet
d'aujourd'hui prudent prudent sur cette
question
de d'être candidat et d'être président
de la République mais c'est pas le sujet
d'aujourd'hui merci pour rester avec moi
vous allez voir ils vont vous faire
réagir nos affranchis pour leur parti
pris qu'on accueille tout de suite
bienvenue à vous
Richard Werny qui revient du crâne je le
disais j'aurais libaudeau de France Info
le brief politique tous les matins 7h24
installez-vous préparez vos cartes
blanches on commence comme chaque soir
par bonbon Express l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée nous est racontée ce soir
par Stéphanie des pierres bonsoir
Stéphanie bonsoir Myriam et l'histoire
du jour c'est celle d'un député insoumis
Éric Coquerel qui est dans le viseur des
macronistes alors Éric Coquerel est
aussi président de la puissante
commission des finances de l'Assemblée
depuis plusieurs semaines il est la
cible de toutes les critiques du camp
présidentielle en toile de fond
rappelez-vous les débats sur la
proposition de loi du pour abroger la
réforme des retraites et plus
précisément sur sa recevabilité au
regard de l'article 40 de la
Constitution alors avant qu'il y a
LeBron Pivet mette un terme au débat
Éric Coquerel avait dit recevoir une
erreur selon la majorité qui ne perd pas
une occasion de le répéter depuis
chacun a fait son devoir à l'exception
et hélas du président de la commission
des finances si vous tenez mes chers
collègues à sanctionner quelqu'un dans
cette affaire pour non respect de la
Constitution vous tenez votre homme la
vraie galinette cendrée c'est le
président de la commission des finances
la galinette cendrée alors autant vous
dire que ça ne fait pas rire tout le
monde Myriam et pas la nupette qui
s'agace qui s'inquiète elle a peur que
la majorité veuille remplacer Éric
Coquerel alors hier les présidents des
quatre groupes de gauche ont envoyé un
courrier officiel à la présidente de
l'Assemblée pour dénoncer des pressions
des attaques contre le président de la
commission des finances et un traitement
inacceptable la gauche accuse pelle mais
les députés les ministres la première
ministre et la présidente du groupe
Renaissance ce qui fait sourire jaune
Aurore berger
ce qui se passe dans l'hémicycle je
crois que ni les menaces ni les
intimidations ni les provocations ne
viennent de la majorité alors est-ce
qu'elle a un plan caché la majorité pour
évincer coquerelles oui Myriam Ali
réfléchit très sérieusement en théorie
les postes clés à l'Assemblée nationale
donc la présidence de la commission des
finances sont attribués pour un an
seulement mais ces postes ne sont que
très rarement remise en jeu les
titulaires les gardent en général durant
5 ans mais cette fois une partie du
groupe Renaissance est très remontée et
bien décidé à tout faire pour ne puisse
pas garder son poste jusqu'en 2027 et
donc à refaire une élection il est
partisan il ne fait pas son job disent
les spécialistes du budget ont lieu à
l'Assemblée on estime qu'en un an il y a
130 amendements sur lesquels Éric
Coquerel aurait dû mettre son veto or il
ne l'a pas fait je n'ai aucun scrupule à
déterrer la hache de guerre nous
expliquait tout à l'heure une députée
Renaissance inverse d'autres sont
beaucoup plus prudents Myriam si on
touche à Éric Coquerel il faut tout
remettre à plat c'est à dire tous les
présidents de commission les
vice-président etc etc il y a ton
intérêt
Eric verte l'ancien chef de la
commission à des finances anciens
républicains désormais Renaissance et
voient très écoutées n'y est pas du tout
favorable bon si je comprends rien c'est
plus facile à dire qu'à faire oui et
c'est ça qui fait hésiter une partie du
camp présidentiel le règlement permet
une nouvelle élection on l'a dit mais ce
serait très inhabituel l'autre règle
plus fondamentale car écrite dans la
Constitution veut que le président de
cette commission des finances soit un
député d'opposition
pour la respecter l'usage veut aussi que
la majorité ne prenne pas par au vote il
faudrait donc remettre en cause ces
usages ça fait beaucoup de conditions ce
qui explique pourquoi le principal
intéressé Erico clay Eric Coquerel n'est
pas très inquiet la majorité peut pas se
présenter contre moi donc il faut que
quelqu'un me positionne qui veulent le
faire puis j'ai entendu aussi monsieur
Marleix ce week-end dire que les
républicains ne joueraient pas ce jeu-là
et sans sans quelqu'un d'une opposition
vous lance mettre en face de moi je vois
pas très bien comment ça peut être fait
Myriam il faut un remplaçant
d'opposition mais pas trop car soutenu
par les macronistes mais pas
complètement désavoués par l'opposition
bref un mouton à cinq pattes le
casse-tête et l'art pour la majorité
qu'il n'y a donc pas tout à fait
définitivement arrêté son plan et là
encore un peu de temps pour y réfléchir
car s'il y a une nouvelle élection ce ne
sera pas avant octobre et vous monsieur
Mattei vous en pensez quoi
je connais bien ricoquerel j'ai eu
l'occasion de faire un rapport lors du
dernier mandat avec lui sur la peau
universelle on sait très bien entendu
je considère qu'il aurait dû déclarer et
recevable le texte au titre de l'article
40 ce texte là
l'iode parce que c'était vraiment un
texte financier qui visait à un projet à
notre texte financier il n'a pas fait
l'assume est-ce que pour autant il faut
changer de prise dans la commission des
finances moi je suis pas favorable je
suis sur la ligne des riverse c'est pas
à nous de choisir le président de
l'opposition je crois que le message est
bien passé donc merci
quelque chose me dit qu'il est pas prêt
de partir Éric Coquerel on continue
merci beaucoup Stéphanie toujours la
politique j'aurais mis vos revenir sur
cette terrible agression à Bordeaux qui
agite le monde politique depuis 24
heures oui vous avez peut-être vu ces
images filmées par un interphone des
images extrêmement choquants d'une rare
violence on ne les diffusera pas ce soir
pour respecter des victimes mais on y
voit une septuagénaire et sa petite
fille agressée sur le pas de leur porte
à Bordeaux ça s'est passé lundi soir
agression abject lâche dont la diffusion
en fait ne doit rien au hasard puisque
c'est d'abord un jeu de politique locale
c'est Nicolas Florian qui diffuse en
premier cette vidéo lui c'est l'ancien
maire LR de Bordeaux pour lui en fait
l'occasion est trop belle de dénoncer le
manque de sécurité dans la ville alors
que depuis et bien il y a eu un maire
écologiste pierre urique donc obligé de
réagir qui dénonce de son côté les
récupérations politiques écoutez c'est
la première fois que je vois de telles
images sur Bordeaux il faut voir la
réalité en face c'est la réalité en face
et qu'aujourd'hui à Bordeaux la sécurité
se dégrade l'état proposé à la ville de
Bordeaux d'avoir un contrat de sécurité
depuis deux ans il est toujours pas
signé je n'entends pas commenter des
réactions qui
non seulement sont indécentes
une centaine dignes je pense à des
réactions de récupération politique
locale et national voilà et en parlant
de récupération ça va vraiment venir
puisque ça va sortir de la sphère locale
petite parenthèse l'agresseur a été
arrêtée très rapidement il souffrirait
de problèmes psychiatriques mais c'est
donc un jeu local qui devient une
affaire assez vite nationale
politique aujourd'hui alors mettons
d'abord les choses au clair le
décryptage politique ne doit pas faire
oublier le fond de la faire oui cet acte
est insupportable on n'ira pas du côté
des des relativistes qui disent que
c'est un fait divers comme un autre non
c'est absolument traumatisant pour
autant regardant les ressorts politiques
qui ont été mis à jour avec une petite
touche de racisme petite touche de
racisme oui le suspect alors on le voit
pas parce qu'on n'a pas vu les images
mais on peut le dire il est noir et ça
fait évidemment les affaires de
l'extrême droite très vite Marine Le Pen
fustige l'insécurité je cite aggravé par
le chaos migratoire immigration
insécurité le la boucle est bouclée
selon elle Eric Zemmour utilise par
défaut le terme de migrants sur BFM TV
le député RN Julien Odoul s'interroge je
le cite les origines de cet homme ne
sont pas bordelaises caramba c'est
encore raté en fait l'homme il est
français de parents français c'est
Gérald Darmanin le ministre de
l'Intérieur qu'il précise l'extrême
droite est ça conception ethnique de la
nation instrumentalisme une agression
presque trop belle pour être vrai au
lieu d'interroger la psychiatrie la
prise en charge des SDF ça n'est que
dans l'après-midi que Jordan Bardella
rétropédale rebondit sur la réponse
pénale pour les multiracidivistes mais
c'est beaucoup plus confortable
évidemment de semer le doute d'amalgamer
une personne non blanche serait par
défaut étrangère ça c'est un vieux
réflexe d'extrême droite mais ce qui est
peut-être encore plus grave c'est qu'on
se rend compte que quand on regarde bien
cette cette espèce de logiciel il se
retrouve dans une bonne partie de la
classe politique il y a pas très
longtemps sur France Info Carl Delga
cherchait les origines de Mbappe et de
Yannick Noah c'est aussi un impensé de
la gauche la question de la couleur de
peau donc non l'histoire de Bordeaux
n'est pas qu'un fait divers ça ne doit
pas faire divers comme disait Bourdieu
cette histoire elle dit beaucoup de
notre société de nos politiques qui
seraient peut-être inspirées de d'abord
répondre aux questions posées par ce
genre de dossier merci en voilà un parti
pris qu'est-ce qu'elle vous inspire
cette affaire et la manière dont elle a
été récupérée il faut avoir beaucoup de
recul je partage un peu et de décence
probablement il faut il faut prendre du
temps de pas s'emballer regarder avec
beaucoup d'humanité penser aux victimes
et autres bien sûr qu'on les prépare
l'émotion mais je crois qu'il faut
chaque fois être très très posé et ne
pas réagir à chaud c'est certainement la
très mauvaise méthode et on achète
lucide avec vous Richard Verdi je le
disais vous reveniez vous revenez du
crâne vous avez une carte blanche ce
soir pour nous parler de cette région de
Donetsk où se déroule la
couper-offensive et vous vouliez nous
parler de ces forces qui défilent
l'Europe les Ukrainiens les appels les
orques effectivement les orques c'est un
nom que je n'avais jamais entendu
prononcé jusque là à propos de l'Ukraine
ni à Paris ni à Bruxelles ni au sein de
l'OTAN alors pour moi peut-être comme
pour vous c'était d'abord c'est assez
c'est aussi et là on se rapproche du
champ de bataille une créature
fantastique du Seigneur des Anneaux chez
Tolkien les orques sont les plus cruels
il a fallu que je me rapproche de la
ligne de front j'y étais encore dimanche
pour comprendre que derrière ce terme se
cache une autre armée c'est les soldats
de Poutine c'est ainsi qu'il se nomme
eux-mêmes et c'est comme ça que tous les
Ukrainiens les désignent tous sur le
front vous parlent des orques le terme
désigne pêle-mêle l'armée régulière les
conscrits les hommes de la ministre
Wagner ou les détenus libérés par le
Kremlin pour aller combattre en première
ligne c'est un mot qui a évidemment
valeur d'avertissement et d'appel au
secours parce que ne pas aider l'Ukraine
c'est la laisser se faire dévorer par
les orques le problème de ces orques et
bien c'est qu'on ne les voit pas ces
jours-ci très peu de prisonniers russes
sont montrés au journaliste
l'information sur la contre-offensive
est verrouillée j'ai pu l'expérimenter
on ne peut pas accéder aux zones de
combat immédiate mais les orques ils
sont là ils rôdent j'ai vu Yelena une
vieille femme dont on a vu l'image
rencontrer près de châssis Viard vous
savez ce localité ou un journaliste de
l'AFP a été tué et bien il a devant moi
cette phrase surréaliste pour elle le
jour des orcs c'est le vendredi c'est
chaque vendredi pareil elle m'a montré
un impact dont but dans son jardin on
était samedi la veille elle était sous
un déluge de feu tombé du ciel vous
allez me dire que Sanry m'a rien que
c'est totalement habillé aberrant et
bien c'est ça la guerre du crâne c'est
des tirs de canon le vendredi ou bien
vous explique-t-on après l'heure du
déjeuner quand les orques sont rassasiés
ces orques évidemment terrifie toutes
les populations en Ukraine oui et parler
des orques c'est aussi signifié que ces
russes là ceux qui sont de l'autre côté
dans les tranchées au cerveau lavé par
la propagande poutinienne ce ne sont
plus les mêmes russes cette même vieille
dame Yelena et bien c'est une enfant de
l'ex-Union soviétique elle est
russophone elle est née dans ce village
à l'ouest de doniesk elle m'a dit
qu'elle ne comprend rien à cette guerre
elle sait juste que le vendredi le ciel
devient l'enfer et on m'a aussi parlé de
contrefensive de bourre repris d'avancer
le crayon moi c'est la guerre des orques
une guerre invisible que j'ai vu à coup
de canon de mortier domicile et des
heures qui sont bien mieux retranchés
équipés bien plus difficile à déloger
qu'en 2022 désorque qui épilennemis et
les civils allaient de drone j'ai pu le
constater comme le font les Ukrainiens
des orgues dans les obus pulvérisent les
hôpitaux comme celui de torrent le 7
juin dernier une cité minière la guerre
des orques c'est celle que l'Europe
rationnelle raisonnable ne comprendra
peut-être jamais une guerre qu'un
tantiste ukrainien juché sur son char
planqué sous le sous les arbres parce
qu'il avait été endommagé ma résumé
d'une phrase nous étions des hommes les
orques de Poutine nous ont tous
transformés en animaux
merci pour ce témoignage merci beaucoup
Richard Verly
l'inhumanité de la guerre c'est
l'humanité je suis glacé parce que ce
que vous dites c'est très impressionnant
bien sûr
on s'arrête là merci beaucoup Richard
werli Jean Rémi Baudot Stéphanie
Despierre à très vite et merci à vous
monsieur le Président Mattei notre passé
nous voir en direct sur LCP soirée
documentaire qui commence maintenant
avec Jean-Pierre Gratien restez avec
nous très belle soirée à demain
[Musique]